the teenager accused of trying to kill  his teacher at el dorado high school has  been deemed competent to stand trial  16-year-old jonathan martinez garcia  appeared in court this morning for that  competency hearing he's facing attempted  murder sexual assault and kidnapping  among other charges martinez garcia's  attorney says the evaluating  psychologist indicated that there were  some issues but didn't state exactly  what those issues are  his attorneys requesting a three-week  time frame to have a follow-up with a  psychologist  evaluating psychologists did indicate  there were some issues  what i'm requesting is to pass this  three weeks  to follow up with the psychologists  and to determine if i'm going to move  forward with an independent evaluation  martinez garcia's next court date  scheduled for may 27th at 8 30 in the  morning